(speaking Chinese)
(Chinese style hip-hop)
- Say Higher!
- [Crowd] Higher!
- Higher!
♪ Higher ♪
(rapping in Chinese)
("Made in China")
- Fuck
(laughing)
(rapping in Chinese)
("Why not")
("Why Not")
(rapping in Chinese)
♪ Why not? ♪
♪ Young Asian got dreads,
romantic, why not? ♪
♪ Air Jordans, skinny jeans,
polo shirt, why not? ♪
♪ Higher gang, rockin' band,
turn the fuck up, why not? ♪
♪ Take a crazy chance, do a crazy dance ♪
(rapping in Chinese)
♪ Ace Hood, Kris Wu, are all my fans ♪
♪ I'm King Kong ... ♪
"Bitch Don't Kill My Dab"
(Chinese style hip-hop)
(phone ringing)
Yo!
- Yo ...
- Yeah, k, k, cool, cool, cool.
- New York City, bruh.
- Say hello to Sean!
- Ay yo, ay yo! Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Hey Sean.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I swear to God, bro.
I promise you.
- OK.
- You want to talk about the Nomad song?
- Yeah, you listen? You listen?
- Yeah, it's fire, it's fire.
I want to make the intro longer.
So I'm going to gave Joji come in here.
The instrumental’s like, really short.
It goes right into the hook, right?
- Yes.
- I want it to be a
little bit longer intro.
You cool with that?
- [MaSiWei] Yeah, I'm cool with that.
- Hell yeah! Hell yeah!
Easy, bro.
I started 88rising about a year
ago with the simple mission
of wanting to the create the
most wavy crew of creators
in history celebrating Asian culture.
Ya know, from Rich really
making history out here,
to the Higher Brothers
becoming the face of hip-hop in
China, and Joji really expanding,
and Keith, it's real just
family environment we're creating,
and putting art into the world.
(Chinese style hip-hop)
- That's crazy, bro.
- See?
- That's fire.
Why did you do it?
(laughing)
- Yo, did that hurt?
- Did the tattoo hurt?
- Nah?
- It was chill. Were you drunk?
(feet stomping)
- Yeah.
- Wow, bro.
- What the hell? You guys are famous, bro!
- That's crazy, bro.
- Wow, bro!
- They look dope.
It looks so dope.
- Oh my God, they're lit.
Yo, they're hitting synchronized ...
- They're bringing their culture into it.
That's what's important.
That's what sticks.
That's what make the shit ...
Amazing.
(chatting in Chinese)
(muffled voices on TV)
(shouting)
- So the Rapper's React franchise,
we did for "Made in China" just recently.
And we had Migos, Yachty,
G Herbo, Playboi Carti,
just a bunch of people just really
big up in the Higher Brothers.
And it's just amazing to
really see that they really
fuck with it, ya know what I mean?
Like, just, in a real way.
Their eyes lit up when they
see these four dudes from China
just killing it.
And having their own
wave, their own style.
I just hope this thing blows up in China.
Really shows the people in
China that they can also do it.
Hopefully just sparks a
whole 'nother generation of
creators out there that, ya know?
If you make good music,
and you do things the right way that,
you know, your music, even
though people don't understand
a word of what you're saying,
can resonate globally.
That's really exciting to us.
- [MaSiWei] Make some
noise for Higher Brothers!
(crowd cheers)
("Isabellae")
(rapping in Chinese)
- Say, say "Higher!"
- [Crowd Higher! Higher!
- Yeah!
(hip-hop instrumental)